in LA this one can never be too cautious
hey man I'm really sorry can I get you
another drink hey boy oh man you just
got it all over my pants in my shoes man
man I'm real sorry I let me get you
another cup man I don't want another
cook yeah watch what you're walking man
man I'm sorry I don't want any problems
I'm gonna get out of here okay we gonna
go man please get your hands off me what
you gonna do about this meal
alhamdulillah assalamo alaikum what does
that mean peace be unto you you will not
find a group of people who are more
inclined towards peace peace with their
Creator peace with themselves peace with
their surroundings then those who follow
that way that way of all the messengers
of God that way of submitting and
surrounding yourself to the Creator and
not his creation now we're going to be
talking about a very important topic
like we always do when somebody takes
that first step and they acknowledge
that there is a Supreme Lord a sovereign
God that is ruling this universe the
create tour and now they want to serve
Him they want to prostrate to him they
want to worship Him alone they take that
necessary step which is the Shahada that
first step many of us have come into
this way of life consciously but now
what happens from here what do you do
from here my next guest is going to help
us tackle this topic we come back my
good friend Sheikh Yasir Qadhi here on
the Dean show will be right back
I love there's only one word and
Muhammad is His Messenger Allah like in
love
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice I said I'm
like oh I Dinkelman said I was a lawyer
but I got to it what do we just say we
just said may peace be unto you we have
a lot of non-muslims for watching the
show every Wednesday here in Chicago if
you're in Chicago they catch us at 12
midnight and those who aren't staying up
there late and following day 2 p.m.
michela they get to learn about what we
just said these low greetings and the
most important thing is the way of life
that we're trying to present to all of
mankind which is that way of all the
messengers Islam yeah now there are many
people who are coming to this beautiful
way of life the FAFSA is going way of
life in the world today but now they
need some encouragement what is the
first step define it when somebody
enters Islam they declare they make that
declaration that there is no deity
worthy of worship except the creator of
the heavens in her and Muhammad peace be
upon him is the last and final messenger
accepting Jesus Moses Abraham and all
the other messages that preceded him
what do they do from here let's spend a
minute talking about what this word what
this phrase means and then let's go on
to the most important thing after that
the prayer the establishment of Prayer
okay well one of the beautiful things
about our religion of Islam is the
emphasis on direct ritual and prayer to
God directly there is no intermediary
there are no superstitious rituals no
strange incantations it's very simple
and very clear if a person wants to
accept Islam they don't need to go to a
church or a mosque or a synagogue they
can do so in the privacy of their houses
even though of course it's encouraged to
publicize the conversion but the actual
conversion is a declaration before you
and god it's a declaration from the one
basically in front of the one who
created you you simply testify and you
acknowledge that this creator is the
only being an entity that is worthy of
worship and veneration it's that simple
and of course that testimony in Arabic
is called the Shahada which basically
translates as testimony the very shahad
that means it's a testimony I am
defying I am bearing witness I am
certain that there is no God that is
worthy of my worship other than the one
true God and in Arabic we call that God
Allah the Allah only means the true God
that's the meaning of Allah as though
God that is worthy of worship so this
testimony basically singles out that one
entity for worship and then we also
testify that God has sent prophets and
messengers and that final prophet and
messenger is our Prophet Muhammad may
God's peace and blessings be upon all
the prophets so after this testimony of
faith a person is a Muslim whether he
did so in front of a million people 10
people or no person if he disowned the
privacy of his house if he testified I
bear witness that there is no God other
than that one true God Allah and that
God has sent prophets and messengers in
the final prophet and Messenger is the
Prophet Muhammad may God's peace and
blessings be upon all of them that is
what makes the Muslim almost look now is
Islam a new religion brought by mohammed
islam is the primordial religion it is
the original religion and the meaning of
Islam is submission so it might have
been manifested in slightly different
ways in terms of practice in terms of
prohibitions in terms of what you can or
can't eat or how you dress or what you
are but the basic teachings and what we
call theology are either belief in God
that does not change so all the prophets
came with the very same message and that
message was quite simple worship God
don't take any partners along with him
that is the gist of Islam and that just
has remained constant it is eternal even
before God created man the same concepts
were there and that is that only he is
worthy of worship and even after there
are no men on earth those concepts will
remain so in that sense Islam has been
permitted however every prophet comes
and those prophets bring slightly
different laws the theology is the same
but laws can change from profit to
profit and this is God takes
circumstances and conditions and time
and place into account and so we do
believe that prophets have come with
slight variations in law but not in
theology and so in that sense Islam is
slightly different from prophet the
prophet but that's only in legal sense
not in the theoretical or in the
theological sense okay before we go on
to that next pillar that establishment
the prayer we want to just talk about
this a little bit more was prevalent in
the world today is that people they say
okay yeah I believe in God I believe in
the crater but then you mentioned
something about a partner what do you
mean that you don't want to put that is
probably the most that's the
unforgivable sin that if you dive down
if you put a partner next to God like
what we see people praying through Jesus
for instance what we got to say about
this well from the Muslims perspective
there is only one God and there are no
partners no entities that are worthy of
any type of veneration of worship other
than that true God so Jesus Christ is a
Messenger of God all of the profits are
messengers that God has sent and these
prophets they might be the best human
beings but they don't impress on if I
God Himself there is no element of
divinity within them so we believe that
the greatest sin any human being can do
is to deny this fact that only God is
worthy of worship and in fact this is
biblical teachings as all the very first
commandment is you shall take no God
other than the true God this is the
first biblical commandment as well that
you cannot worship any other God and it
is the same in our religion as well the
greatest sin which has a greater sin
than anything you can do it to a human
being is to transgress against God
himself and to say to God basically in
action if not in speech that you're not
worthy of worship this dead person is
worthy of worship or this Idol is worthy
of worship I'm going to dedicate the
most precious thing that I have and that
is my my humility my humbleness my
sacrifice my prayer I'm going to
dedicate that to an entity that doesn't
deserve it and I'm going to worship a
being that you have created this is an
insult and an affront to God and that is
why God has said he will not forgive
this in anybody who does so knowing that
there's one true God and he dedicates
his life to another God even if he
believes in the true God but his worship
is dedicated to another guard then this
is what we call in Arabic ship which
means associating partners with God and
that's a type of polytheism now problem
comes when you say the word polytheism
in the English language the only thing
that comes to mind is idol worship yeah
that's the only thing it comes to mind
but it's it's deep
within that you don't have to have an
idol to commit polytheism you can of
course you know have an idol in be a
polytheistic but you can be polytheistic
without an idol as well if you pray to a
saint if you pray to a dead person if
you prostrate out of respect and
humility and worship to another created
object if you sacrifice trying to please
like these pagan sacrifices ritual
sacrifices now we don't have human
sacrifices in our religion but we do
sacrifice animals right we kill animals
now when we kill an animal we're allowed
to kill an animal because God has told
us so when we kill an animal we ritually
sacrificed a cow or a sheep to eat it we
have to mention the name of the Creator
who created that animal because that's
the Creator that give us that right to
take that animal's life now if a person
mentions another god person mentions
another entity that is dedicating a
ritual to other than God and that is
polytheism so let me define polytheism
around polytheism is to give the rights
of a lot to other than a lot to give the
rights of god to other than god anything
that is due to god if you give it to
other than god you are being
polytheistic gotcha now you mentioned
blood and you mentioned sacrifice just
to emphasize this point now that blood
God doesn't eat because some people feel
that okay God sent his son to die for
the sins of the world that blood
sacrifice that animal is for now what
for the poor yeah this is a very very
different concept from Islam compared to
other religions yeah many religions have
this concept that you do need to
sacrifice blood in order to you know
appease God in the Quran very clearly
says the verse in the Quran that clearly
says the blood and the meat does not
reach God God doesn't need this blood
and the meat rather what reaches God is
your piety yeah is your dedication now
one of the ways to show dedication
especially more in the past is to show
that this animal you will sacrifice it
for the sake of God meaning what does it
mean in our religion it means you
dedicate that meat to the poor to the
poor that's what it means now you've got
no longer you don't need a doctor what
you've done is you shown that you're
willing to spend money to take something
very precious whether it's a cow or a
sheep or goat and to use that
money for people who need it and that's
the poor that's what God likes God
doesn't need the blood and the meat God
wants to see your piety that piety is
shown by mentioning his name and
thanking him and then distributing that
meat to the poor and that is what we do
every year on the day of sacrifice is
called Alba the great the grandest
festival of the Muslims is on that day
of sacrifice and we're supposed to
sacrifice an animal mention in God's
name and we're supposed to give at least
a portion of the meeting we're allowed
to eat a little bit but we give supposed
to give a portion of the meat to those
who need it that is what sacrifice
entails in our village what you just
said I'm sure the true seeker the one
who's really using his mind and the good
old common sense that God has given all
of us I just it just makes sense you
don't have to jump through hoops through
a bunch of mental gymnastics I don't
make it fit so anybody who believes this
and he testifies to it with his lips and
then his actions that's what we want to
go to now the action the prayer you have
many people who have submitted to this
first step but now how do we encourage
them because I've seen some people
masha'Allah all things instead of crated
that they've come along quickly some
people it's been a few years they still
have not established the five daily
prayers talk to us you now that is
definitely a major problem that we are
facing in our times and that is Muslims
believe in Islam but unfortunately many
of them don't really follow its
injunctions fully and one of the most in
fact the fact the matter the most
important injunction after the testimony
of faith is the prayer and it the reason
is very simple and that is because the
prayer is what shows you're constantly
thinking and worshiping and thanking God
and that is why the prayer is a daily
routine it's at specified intervals or
five specific intervals that we're
supposed to just stop everything and the
beauty of it it's not an exact time at
1202 we have to stop no is always a
range between let's say 1230 22 there
depending on the time of the year
whether there's different time is but
there's two three four or five hours
arranged within those hours we're
expected to stop what we're doing go
into a corner into a room into a mosque
it doesn't matter anywhere the whole
world you can / you can pray in the park
and you just spend two
four minutes dedicated to a lot to God
and that basically shows you're
consistently thinking about God you're
consistently remembering that I'm a
Muslim and need to pray and the prayer
is there's no doubt it is the most
important principle of a religion after
this is a testimony of faith and that is
what occurs in the very first verse in
the Quran that those who establish the
prayer the very first chapter of the
Quran praises those who establish the
purse with Al Baqarah mental after the
introduction and our Prophet peace be
upon him the very last phrases that he
said before he died is I caution you
about abandoning the prayer make sure
you guard the prayer those were the last
words before he died that he wanted us
to remember so really the prayer is a
sign of your faith now you see this is a
key point here yeah the word faith when
you say it in English primarily the
first thing that comes to mind is what
you believe theory its intellectual in
Islam it's not just intellectual faith
is followed up by actions yes because
the actions prove the faith exists and
that's we know this in real life when
you love a person you will give what you
want what that person wants you will
sacrifice to please that person you will
give up your time your effort you know
we're all married men here we love our
wives we love our kids you dedicate most
of your day to taking care of their
needs yeah you sacrifice most of your
paycheck for their needs that's what you
call love now if you didn't if there's a
person who you know God forbid was a bad
person and he didn't take care of his
wife he didn't take care of his kids
doesn't matter what he says he does not
love them it's that simple right actions
speak louder than words we all know that
so in Islam there is no concept of faith
being something that's hidden and
theoretical in Islam faith is manifested
in actions there's no doubt that there's
an a theoretical element I believe in
God I believe I have to pray but if I
don't follow it up in action then
there's a problem isn't there yeah so
that action proves the true faith and
that is why the primary manifestation of
faith in the life of the Muslim the
primary not even this is the primary
manifestation is the fact that
he pretty he's praying five times a day
hmm how can a person get to because when
you see and you talk to individuals and
I've had the experience from talking to
certain individuals they're having
issues problems the first question I
asked usually is are you establishing
the prayer and if a person isn't I
usually see that there's a problem here
because if you're not establishing the
prayer you're not connected with the guy
from up above so but on the other end
you'll see the same individual reading
tons of book on how to be a successful
businessman all worldly things but they
can't fathom they can't imagine the idea
that okay me praying five times a day is
going to bring me this you know peace
and serenity and how do we deal with
this how we tackle this in fact when a
person establishes a relationship with
God when a person is constantly thinking
about God two things happen firstly
there's the issue of God Himself
blessing that person there's an
undeniable fact if you are a good person
God will give you blessings generally by
and large those who are righteous and
good people they live better lives in
terms of quality not necessarily
quantity yeah you know but in terms of
enjoying their lives right and the
second issue is regardless of material
what you have what you know what you
don't have internally you feel a sense
of peace you feel a sense of comfort
knowing that there's a God who cares
about you and who loves you and who will
bless you if flannels Fort Lee hereafter
so there's two elements there's an
external element and there's an internal
element and prayer and relationship with
God overall even broader than prayer is
a relationship with God prayer is of
course the most important manifestation
of that relationship you can't have a
relationship with God and not pray it's
that simple right yeah you can claim it
as much as you want if you don't pray as
a Muslim you don't have a relationship
with God so having a relationship with
God and in particular the prayer what it
does is it brings you a coolness of the
heart a comfort of the heart makes you
feel peace at peace because you are
doing what you're supposed to do which
is a worship of God and along with that
it brings about God's blessings as well
God will send upon you and shower upon
you his mercy and his blessing
which is far more important than money
or other material possessions and you
will start enjoying the quality of life
even if you don't have the quantity that
other people have and that's one of the
biggest problems is that we judge
happiness by quantity no it's by quality
and that is why our beloved prophet
sallallaho said in peace be upon him he
said the truly rich person is not the
one who has lots of goods it's the one
who's content in what he has means he
enjoys what a God has given him and he
loves the quality of life he's content
with what he has any enjoys it so if you
have a thousand ten thousand a million
and you enjoy that amounted you have
that that that quality that is what will
make you happy otherwise if you're
always greedy for more the millionaire
wants to become the billionaire the
billionaire was to become the
multi-billionaire always greedy for more
and more and more that's not going to
bring happiness quality versus quantity
relationship with God will give you the
quality now does that come and fall back
on what we said that first pillar that
now okay I'm not worshipping Jesus I'm
not worshipping saints or going through
Saints okay I'm not doing any of that
but the call for prayer comes and I
can't get away from the TV or the music
or this or that something worldly and
this is it becomes an annoyance now
we're going to say about this year
that's definitely a problem that's
definitely a problem there's a verse in
the Quran that clearly describes the
believers as those who their houses
their families their their their
livelihood their businesses do not
prevent them from worshipping God and
establishing the prayer they don't
prevent them because if they do prevent
then there's another reason the Quran
whoever false way to the desires of this
world at the expense of the hereafter
that's the real loser because you've
lost this world when you die and you've
lost the hereafter after your death the
real loser according to the Quran you've
lost this world and the next when you
dedicate it to this world because when
you die what's gonna happen all of the
goods that you have are out of your hand
doesn't matter how much you've amassed
you can't even go to you can't take it
with about the big all the billions
millions thousands your own the people
who bury you huh they're gonna be the
ones fighting over it the ones who
supposedly love you the most within the
day that you die they're gonna be almost
fists physicals and fight over your
millions and billions that's the reality
of life that we see
around us now someone also okay they
come and they've been speaking the
English language all their life and now
they got to learn all this Arabic and
they feel like okay this is overbearing
how am I going to memorize all these new
terms and terminologies to establish the
prayer they find it difficult yeah
that's a very good point that's a very
good point a number of things can be
said here first and foremost the
immediate convert the person who
converts to Islam you know suppose
somebody converts today so there's no
doubt that you cannot memorize so much
in in five seconds or five minutes next
time the prayer comes along maybe two
hours from now you're not expected to
have all of this memorized you're
allowed for an interim until you
memorize you're allowed to make do with
translation make do with holding a paper
and reading from it make do with saying
you know praise be to God and just doing
what you can for that particular day or
two until you memorize the first chapter
which is sort of odd to have you
memorized the key phrases and these
should not take more than a day or two
just to memorize the key phrases right
so go to any Muslim friend any mosque
and they'll teach you these key phrases
so within a few days you should have
enough to basically have the prayer done
and slowly but surely you'll memorize
more and more so that's the first point
take it easy and realize you don't have
to start memorizing the entire Quran you
know today it to start your prayer it'll
take a day or two in that meantime start
learning how to pray start learning the
moves start learning various phrases the
second point I want to say the power of
the Quran is really really unimaginable
because the Quran is the actual speech
of God so do not underestimate your
capacity to memorize the Quran you will
see for yourself that after you read it
a few times it's going to stick in your
head because it's got I don't use the
word magical qualities and I'd say
divine qualities if because it's divine
it is divine the Quran is the actual
speech that God spoke yeah therefore and
you will notice this when you hear the
Quran I challenge you right now and
you're if you're watching this online
you know go to a website YouTube type in
Quran recitation and listen to the Quran
in proper arabic you won't understand
the word but it will have an impact on
you that you have never experienced in
your life ticket take the challenge
right now and that is a proof that this
is something that is diff
so do not underestimate your own
capacity to memorize this foreign
strange language in Arabic it will be
easy for you because this is the speech
oh my god in your god so they don't have
to have a whole chapter memorized right
away they can do like you said the
phrases start the movements yeah the
first day or two of course is there not
expected to have memorized due to the
fact how would they convert you know so
the factor has the first surah and it is
an essential requirement of the prayer
it's only seven lines it's it's seven
lines it's pat one paragraph that's it
so you know the first time a person
becomes a Muslim suppose he converted at
ten a.m. then Laura's gonna come to the
first pair in 3-4 hours he's not
expected to memorize that so either he
just says you know praise be to God or
you know glory be to God or he memorizes
the English you know for that time or he
holds up the Arabic transliteration
approach yeah hold it up in there better
pray so the point being there is no
difficulty in the religion it's easy for
you until you memorize and when you
memorize then slowly but surely keep on
adding a few more chapters as you go
along and things will be easy after that
so take one step better take one step at
a time just like you took all them steps
to finish it got a PhD exactly it upon
whatever GED you took some whatever
happened you acted you have to start
from somewhere didn't you have the
famous saying of Confucius of a journey
of a thousand miles begins with one step
that's the way you have to do it yeah
now ok few more points before we come to
a close with my special friend yasir
qadhi tell us now knowledge is key you
need knowledge back to what action again
you can read a ton of books on one side
when it comes down here to learn about
your Creator how do we get people more
focused on the other side balancing it
out you don't have to obviously leave
off this other good knowledge on how to
become the best whatever scientist dr.
Loar etc but we want people to be more
enthusiastic about seeking knowledge and
the rewards of it yeah this is a very
important point and knowledge has always
been associated with our religion of
Islam from day one the very first
revelation that came down was to recite
and to read and this recitation came
down upon a group of people who were
absolutely illiterate the Arabs did not
even have a sophisticated writing system
that a very rudimentary system and the
first revelation that comes upon an
unlettered illiterate community
even our Prophet Muhammad Saleh son
could not read or write and the first
commandment is to recite and to read and
to basically get some knowledge that's
the first commandment and it was because
of that that our the people of our
religion and Muslims they took this
commandment and they reached pinnacles
that no other civilization ever reached
before them in every single science
because they were curious whether it's
religious science or secular science
unfortunately that spirit is very much
destroyed in our times and people just
don't have that enthusiasm that they do
even though it is a part of our religion
to have that enthusiasm and all I can
say is being ignorant something nobody
likes no nobody likes to be ignorant it
is it is an insult to be called ignorant
why would you want to have this
adjective describing you and the
religion don't be ignorant of your
religion is the most important science
and the world why will you created why
are you here what are you doing with
your life what are you going to do after
you die what's going to happen after
you're dead these are fundamental
questions that every human being has to
think about and has to rationalize it
and come to a conclusion and these days
it's so easy to find out what our
religion other religions say these days
you just find out on the internet go to
the local library and get it straight
from you know from the people like with
animals horses mouth get it from the
people who believe get it from the
proper sources and simply read some
articles this in some lectures do some
some research and within the span of a
few hours you will educate yourself
about the basic belief of Muslims the
basic belief of God they hear after the
day of judgement it is essential even
just as an rational human being that you
understand what other people say and
what other people believe in and that's
the first step to familiarize into to
reach out and to you know form
neighborly connections to basically like
you start off with the peace on earth
that's how we're going to have peace on
earth is to understand into to
sympathize and empathize with what we
all believe thank you very much for
being with us a guy pleasure good fresh
a gas Arkady and we hope to see you back
again on the Dean show is that my god
almighty allah reward you for all your
efforts and work and thank you for
coming back every week to see us here
and the Dean show you don't know if
you're going to live till tomorrow
you have to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now get connected with
your Lord get connected with the one who
gives you the air to breathe do the good
that he's told you to do and there's
nothing less than paradise that is what
we're trying to achieve and we'll see
you back here next week every Wednesday
Midnight's thursdays 2 p.m. if you're
here in Chicago if you're not you can
catch us at the Dean show com where we
have all of our shows there for free
we'll see you next time inshallah sound
like them peace be unto you one can
never be too cautious hey man I'm really
sorry can I get you another drink hey
boy oh man you just got it all over my
pants in my shoes man mana I'm real
sorry I let me get you another cup man I
don't want another cook yeah watch what
you're walking man man I'm sorry I don't
want any problems I'm gonna get out of
here okay we're gonna go man please get
your hands off me what you're gonna do
about it up oh thank you oh you mean my
cool do manacled my arm man yeah i got
you managed I've had enough in here Oh
one can never be too cautious
hey man what you learned that I trained
you to the Gracie Baja you got time I'll
show you come on remember these
techniques only for life-threatening
situations self defense ok come on and
see what everyone's talking about whoo
if you find one contradiction it can't
be from God but the rational idea the
rational explanation is you do your best
give up for spring guide is why I will
never give up spending this message the
reality of life usually doesn't sink in
until tragedy commas you get a few bad
people the media grabs ahold of that and
spends it the way they want to if you
say that you're not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of its none you
cannot be a Muslim and attended our
faith to
guys let's look at the technique that we
applied earlier we call it a shoulder
lock it's going to be where the
aggressor is going to place his arm onto
my shoulder okay there's two variations
of this self-defense technique one is if
just like so the guy grabs you by the
shoulder but you notice the elbows bent
or lose the second variation is gonna be
where that he has my shoulder but his
arm is stiff okay this is going to be
another variation that we will not cover
today the one that we're going over is
shoulder grab bent arm okay so how does
he's going to place his hand on my
shoulder now i'm going to use the same
side that he's controlling i'm going to
use that arm to come up and above his
elbow i come up and as soon as i get to
this point now i'm using his group
against him okay his grip his wrist is
secured tightly under my armpit i'm
going to go palm to palm and now making
sure that his wrist is secured under my
armpit i'm gonna start to raise his
elbow up applying the pressure onto his
shoulder okay let's take a look at that
one more time same sign he's attacking
comes up and over the shoulder at this
point I have to really focus on making
his grip tight under my armpit if the
grip is loose is just going to pull his
arm out okay which gets rid of the grip
that can be another way of just
disengaging but we're going to try and
take advantage of the situation okay it
comes up come under the elbow I go palm
to Palm I secure his grip and now i
start to raise elevate the elbow up as I
raise the elbow up elbow up trapping his
wrist that's where he starts to feel the
pressure under ligaments of his shoulder
okay and we saw one example of how to
defuse the situation with jujitsu the
beautiful thing about you is that you
don't need to hurt okay punish the guy
to defuse the situation if I decided
earlier to punch or to kick the
aggressor I'm not defusing the situation
I'm just increasing the chances of that
becoming an extreme situation a big
headache okay one more time Oh over and
now I have the option maybe he's not in
the best situation to now be an
aggressor I have him at my mercy at the
moment I can talk to him I can defuse
the situation god forbid if I need to
really defend my life there is the
possibility of putting the pressure on
the shoulder to do some real damage but
and should not come to that okay we can
talk the fuels in the field that I'm the
situation is diffused can let it go and
situations down without harming their
aggressive that's it for today's episode
of the self-defense workshop until next
time guys be safe
you
you